do you know what the realm is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what do we have left once we abandon the
lie chaos what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back from a final breakdown of
this Game of Thrones season ain't plot
league and my last one I finished up by
giving my thoughts on what this league
said happens during the Great War
it says the night King was after gillies
baby and John ends up stabbing
Melisandre through the heart but now
that out whenever that it's time to move
on to King's Landing and ultimately what
happens after all the battles are done
so I want to begin by talking about
their plan to sneak into King's Landing
according to this plot leak it says
Jamie and Ariana kin to the red keep
together that way Jamie can find Cersei
and Arya can wear the face of a guard
and hopefully open up a gate to allow
the rest of them inside the city like
with most of this leak it's hard to
really confirm or deny anything right
now because there haven't been a whole
lot of quality photos taken from the
sense there were plenty of photos taken
in the north during the Great War but
even in those photos you can't really
make out who is who I think most of us
assume there will be a war in King's
Landing
Daenerys has no intentions of leaving
Cersei and power of the Seven Kingdoms
and Cersei has no intentions of stepping
down either so someone will have to be
forced out of the way there isn't enough
room for two queens which means one of
them will most likely die as a result of
this most of us have seen the photos of
Jon Snow in King's Landing with Cersei
Lannister
but those definitely could be faked
scenes to throw us fans off of their
scent but there are also some photos of
a massive set they have built which will
be used for scenes in King's Landing one
of the pictures shows the wall partially
collapsed which most likely means a
battle will take place in and around the
red keep plus we all remember the vision
Daenerys had at the house of the undying
the throne room was completely destroyed
and considering bran stark had this same
vision
it leads me to believe this is something
we will see happen in the future so I am
pretty confident we will see some action
in King's Landing but will it play out
the way this leek says I will admit that
I kind of like their plan to enter the
red keep through the storm drain this
could actually work especially with Aria
since she can move like a ninja and
disguise herself to be almost anyone
when Aria was in King's Landing she used
to train by chasing around cats and she
chased one all the way down into the
lower levels of the red cape where all
the dragon skulls were kept when she did
this she was interrupted by Varys and
Ilario discussing their planes Aria
hides and eventually gets lost in the
dark down there but she finds her way
out through a storm drain that empties
right into the Blackwater Bay assuming
this drain is still set up the same way
Arya and Jaime could wait until night
falls and quietly row a boat up to the
shore right next to the drain and enter
the red keep this way without anyone
really knowing they were there
if Arya could get inside she could kill
someone and wear their face then she
wouldn't have to worry about hiding she
would just have to hide the person's
body somewhere out of sight
this leek says after they get inside the
red key they go their separate ways
Jaime works his way up the Circe's
chambers and aurilla slips back outside
into the city where she quickly kills a
guard and uses him as a disguise then
she begins to kill everyone that is
manning the ballistas until someone
discovers a body and they sound the
alarms then all hell breaks loose which
causes John and Daenerys to move to plan
B which is stormed the city with the
Dragons now before I get into that let
me give you my thoughts on this aria and
Jaime mission let's be honest here is
this scenario really going to happen
next season these two characters
becoming partners in crime sounds a
little too forced in my opinion I think
Arya is more likely to kill Jaime and
where his face before she would ever
work with him but to be fair there isn't
really any way for me to prove this is
fake as of right now however if I base
this on the characters personalities I
doubt Arya would be willing to part
with Jamie unless they saw no other
option of gaining access to the city
without getting people killed if we want
to believe that the set photo is real
then it appears as if John goes to
King's Landing to try and strike some
kind of a deal with Cersei but I am
assuming something will go wrong there
was also a report that came out that
said Game of Thrones is going to be
filming in the dragon pit again so
perhaps we could get another parler
scene between some of the major players
from this story whatever happens I don't
think it's gonna end well with Cersei
because I just don't see her bowing down
to Daenerys or packing up her bags and
leaving the city there is evidence of
King's Landing set being destroyed in
even reports that have said the King's
Landing set will be caught on fire which
always seemed likely to me mostly based
on Daenerys and brains vision of the
throne room being burnt so that leads me
to the next part of this leak because it
says once the guards are alerted that
someone is inside the city gates and
killing people this causes them to sound
the alarm and John and Daenerys open up
the attack with the Dragons it's hard to
say if John will actually ride Ragle but
I fully believe we will see Daenerys
barn King's Landing down to some
capacity I have a feeling King's Landing
will no longer be the capital of
Westeros once everything is said and
done I believe even the Iron Throne will
be destroyed this leaks says John uses
regel to blow out a hole in the side of
the wall that way he can allow the rest
of his men to get inside the city this
could be true to a certain extent
because there are photos of the King's
Landing sent and there is a big hole in
the side of the wall once the men are
inside the Hound ends up seeing his
brother walking along the top of the
wall igniting the pots of wildfire and
this is when cleganebowl begins
personally I have always felt we would
see cleganebowl at some time and after
the Hound confronted his brother during
the parlay scene that made me even more
confident based on what the Hound said
to him in case you don't remember the
Hound said you know who's coming for you
you've always known the Hound is
obviously referring to himself their
relationship will end in a Cain and Abel
fashion
it says the hound eventually kills him
by smashing upon a wildfire over his
head then throwing a torch onto him
which causes the mountain to basically
melt inside of his Armour this is
interesting because this may be the only
way to kill the mountain he might as
well be a white like the creatures in
the army of the Dead
he was already hard to kill before and
now that he's reanimated plus he wears
very big armor it's probably gonna be
hard to kill him with just a sword
unless you cut off his damn head and who
knows if that would even work because
many people believe he doesn't even have
a head in the books burning him alive
what wildfire should do the trick it
might even be the final step into hounds
metamorphosis in order for him to get
over his fear of fire he may have to
kill his brother with fire once again
there is no evidence of this scene
playing out like this but I don't think
it's a terrible idea now let's talk
about the Kingslayer scenes in this plot
link after the city watch rings the
alarms Jaime Lannister quickly makes his
way up to Circe's chambers Qyburn is
preparing to go down into the black
cells and like the wildfire but Euron
goes with him apparently you're on
planned on fleeing the city it says
Jaime hides around the corner and waits
for them to walk past and when they do
Jaime jumps out and he jams bronze
dagger into Kai burns neck
Qyburn falls to the floor then Jaime and
Euron grab each other and fall to the
ground
Jaime is able to knock out Euron's teeth
with his golden hand then he pulls the
dagger out of Kai burns neck and he
plunges it into Euron's chest Jaime
leaves him there for dead any heads into
Circe's chambers covered in blood
now before I talk about the Jaime and
Cersei scene let me give you my opinion
on what happened to Qyburn and Euron I'm
not 100% sold on the idea of Euron
disappearing after this scene I have
always believed Joran would die and it
would be by the hands of another Greyjoy
I think either Theon or Yara will kill
their uncle you're on and I leaned more
towards Theon being the one to do this
because this may be the final hurdle
Theon needs to get over just like the
Hound has to do with his brother the
mountain in order for Theon to overcome
his fears and complete his own
metamorphose
he needs to defeat his uncle you're on
he is already on his way of
accomplishing this feat John helped
Theon with his identity crisis when he
told Theon he was a stark and a Greyjoy
that helped Theon come to terms with who
he was and he also got some closure now
that he knows John isn't going to kill
him for what he had done that was just
enough to give Theon the courage to go
outside and demand that he get his
sister Yara back he even defended
himself and fought back finally then he
bent down into the sea and washed the
blood off of his face which is kind of
symbolic as a baptism by sea what is
dead may never die but rises again
harder and stronger I am now confident
that Theon will not stop until he finds
his sister and there is a very good
chance that Theon or Yara died in the
process of him trying to save her but I
think you're on will die as well but
this is just my opinion so I can't agree
with this part of the leak that says
your own gets stabbed by Jaime than his
body is missing afterwards however on
the other hand I do think Qyburn can die
by Jaime killing him I actually made a
video a very long time ago and I said if
Jaime does kill Cersei then he will most
likely kill Qyburn first this would
basically repeat history from the time
Jaime killed the mad Kings Pyromancer to
prevent him from letting the wildfire
before then Jaime killed the mad king
afterwards Jaime could find himself in a
similar position where he has to kill
Qyburn before he lights any wildfire
then he would of course kill Cersei and
fulfill the valonqar prophecy at the
same time so I do think this is very
possible and I actually like the idea
but the big question is well Jaime be
the one to kill Cersei according to this
plot lake Jaime strangles her to death
Circe's death by strangulation was
prophesized in the books but they left
that part out of Maggie the frogs
prophecy even though that wasn't
mentioned in the show they will still
probably have Jaime kill her and I think
they may have left that part out because
they didn't want people to know Cersei
would die perhaps they wanted that to
come as a surprise but there is no way
to know for sure
Jaime maybe the valonqar in the show but
I don't think he will be the valonqar in
the books
my friend gray area made the most
convincing valonqar video in my
for the books she believes euron greyjoy
will be the valonqar and the way she
presents the theory and lays out the
evidence makes a ton of sense to me
however in the show they will probably
just go with Jamie because they didn't
set up the valonqar prophecy correctly
so I would say this part of the leek has
a very high chance of coming true King's
Landing is mostly destroyed by the time
the fighting stops
the throne room is burnt up just like we
have seen in Dany and brains visions
which is something I always believed
what happened in season 8 so I agree
with this part as well there haven't
been any set photos yet that show any
signs of this happening to the actual
throne room but there is enough clues in
the show that lead me to believe it's
true
Plus Daenerys said her seeing what the
vision was shot indoors with the
green-screen so we will never see a
leaked photo of that anyway unless it
was done outdoors where fans can snap a
quick photo after this the leek says
there is pretty much a montage scene of
some of the kingdoms being restored
which kind of makes sense considering
most of Westeros has been at war since
the very beginning of the series I am
assuming the night king and his army
will wipe out most of the north in
Winterfell will burn to some extent but
I doubt the castle will be completely
destroyed Daenerys is also visibly
pregnant by this time which would also
make sense since the baby was most
likely conceived during the season 7
finale when Jon and Daenerys sailed to
white Harbor together the rest of the
plot lake is pretty basic in my opinion
they basically just decide who will get
what lands and who will rule those areas
all of this will be shot indoors so
there is no way to know how much of it
if any of it will happen Dan and Dave
are directing the last episode so I
don't expect there to be too much action
in the finale they brought back Miguel
supporting two direct episodes three and
five since he is a genius at directing
action sequences I assume they will wrap
up all the fighting in his episodes
which makes perfect sense to me but once
again this is just my opinion
it also says Jon and Daenerys will Wed
in winterfell's godswood before she
gives birth and I kind of expected this
to happen since jon has always said he
never wanted the father a bastard
in order for this to happen both of them
will have to survive the wars which
isn't a guarantee with this being the
last season they could kill off just
about anyone let's just hope it makes
sense with the overall story there is
one thing in this finale that I find
very interesting it says brain stark
becomes very ill now that the night king
is defeated apparently it's very similar
to what happened with Jojen Reed during
season four
The Closer Jojen got to completing his
task of delivering brand to the
three-eyed Raven the sicker Jojen became
his body just started to break down
which is what it sounds like is
happening to bran in this plot leaked
and I know some people have theorized
that once the magic has gone from the
world it could kill bran
since he's the last green seer I have to
say it would be pretty damn sad if bran
just started to wither away like this I
always knew there was a chance another
stark could die but I was hoping they
could survive now that the pack is
together
the lone wolf dies but the pack survives
what do you all think about this do you
think bran could die if the magic went
away I suppose it's possible but I am
hoping he just loses his greensight
since he would no longer need it anyway
the last three-eyed Raven was still
alive even though there was no dragons
or red comet streaking across the sky he
was in that tree long before the dragons
hatched so I don't see why brain would
have to die because of this
unless bran needs to be intertwined with
the tree to keep some power or life in
him I really don't know how that works
and I don't think anyone does other than
just speculating but other than what I
have said already there really isn't
much else I can add or subtract from
what the plot league says this episode
seemed kind of boring for the most part
but like I said earlier once the
fighting is done there aren't going to
be too many more exciting scenes
besides Daenerys possibly giving birth
or maybe some marriages here are there
so I think this pretty much wraps it up
for my breakdown of the Game of Thrones
Season 8 plot League the first few
episodes seemed reasonable for the most
part but right around episode 4 & 5 is
where the story started to slip in my
opinion let me know what you think about
this one though if there was anything I
said that you agree or disagree with put
it down in the comment section let's
discuss what's likely
are not so likely to happen in the end
anyways I want to thank you all for
coming along for this ride I really
appreciate that and I also want to thank
every one of you who support this
channel on patreon I hope you have a
great day and I hope to see you all come
back for the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]